pour ce dentiste guyancourt toi les
soins ont repris comme avant le coc vide
ou presque
le nombre de consultations quotidiennes
et réduit de moitié
l'organisation a été revu je les
installe très rapidement dans cette
pièce masqué et j'attends éventuellement
au moins 20 minutes entre entre la fin
de ma décontamination sur le nettoyage
complet rinçage nettoyage des surfaces
etc
si surtout j'ai utilisé des airs au sol
des aérosols ou c'est à dire une turbine
que j'essaye d'éviter d'utiliser et puis
un détartrage comme de nombreux
praticiens ce dentiste a totalement
fermé son cabinet à l'annonce du
confinement avant de se porter
volontaires pour assurer les urgences
avait plus du tout de matériel j'entends
lui matériel c'est plutôt les masques
ffp2 qui nous posait des problèmes
encore peu en ce qui nous concerne
j'avais beaucoup de matériel parce que
je fais de la chirurgie et que je fais
d'enseignement au niveau de la chirurgie
on a été approvisionné avant les gardes
par le conseil de l'ordre à douma leader
à versailles de trois jours avant pour
aller chercher notre matériel et surtout
préparer les salles
plus de 270 chirurgiens dentistes ont
été mobilisés durant le confinement rage
de dents traumatisme et hémorragies ont
été les principales causes de soins nous
avons institué un système de garde sept
jours sur sept avec des régulateurs pour
pouvoir enregistrer les appels de
patients et les régulateurs distribués
sur trois voire quatre voire cinq
binômes de léran faut savoir que dans
les binômes de garde
nous avions cette unité que deux
chirurgiens dentistes puisque les
assistantes ne pouvait pas bien entendu
exercer le numéro d'urgence a été
composé plus de 5200 fois en 45 jours
depuis le déconfinement les 1030 quatre
praticiens ont repris leur activité dans
le département